are you guys doing today very good thank
you how are you
fun times this is this is an interesting
way to do a junket yeah I definitely
want to start with one of the things
that I love so much about Ryan Murphy
it's his to both diversity and inclusion
in front of and behind him I wanted to
know if you guys could sort of talk
about that and the importance of
representation and especially in a show
like this series yeah
that was my first question to Ryan was
you know we're talking about the 40s and
50s and I said me being a black artist
and talking about my character Archie he
would have to move a little bit
differently just because things were
different there was segregation there
was all types of things happening but I
asked him would there be people in the
writers room
you know crew members that look like me
or was I going to be you know what was
they going to because I hadn't worked
with Ryan and it was it was it was
diverse there were so many colors and
waves and types of people and it was a
family I got to work very closely with
Janet mock who was a producer on the
show in the writers room and also
directed two of the episodes and she
kind of became a lifeline for me during
this process because she is an
incredible woman but a woman of color
and I was able to just have certain
conversations with her and get certain
guidance about what it is we're after
tonally overall as an arc for Archie but
made it an incredible experience and in
itself the battle for equal
representation and opportunities for
people of color women and you know
members of the LGBTQ community is still
being waged today so this was a
inspiring story and it felt like such an
honor to be a part of something that was
you know had that kind of commentary but
more than that you're really falling in
love I think with just what these people
are going through and what they're
willing to do it's quite interesting I'd
only add that it's almost ironic but
it's kind of like to to have more
different types of people working on the
same project it was a very diverse group
and not coincidentally but without
thinking about it when I was there
it was one of the most creative in a
very literal sense it was just such a
colorful creative atmosphere and it's
exactly what you would ever want to to
be a part of and so it's like there were
there are rewards that that come from
this kind of collaboration with this
this many different types of people that
I just don't think you see coming until
you're part of it and then you're like
why don't we do this all the time so I
don't know if any of you guys read these
comic books called what if there were
big it's like a an old comic book like
what if Batman had defeated Superman or
whatever and I felt like this series was
what if Hollywood had embraced diversity
and sexuality in the 1940s you can sort
of talk about maybe if you could talk
about that again it's this fantasy this
idea this what if and I think especially
now with us being quarantined it's
something that should feel at least when
I watched it very hopeful and inspiring
it's it's made me think about the type
of art that I choose in the future and
what I'm excited to get back to when you
know when we get back to that time of
getting back to work and all again yes
yes and amen
and I would say I I was fortunate enough
to play a character who whose art and
life was directly affected by the what
if choices made by the young people in
the system by the studio people in our
fictional system when those choices that
didn't really happen in real life when
they were made you see the effects it
might have what if happened to a
character like the one that I played and
and the ripple effect that had on I
won't spoil it but the way the series
ends what's the next step in our world
that's going on and I don't think that's
hard to imagine that that that's not
that far from what how things work in
real
life one bold step is made and at least
all these others I check I'll actually
ask you a specific when I was watching
the series i perfectly try not to learn
too much but there is a moment with your
character that he makes a choice and
it's like right at that moment that the
entire series sort of takes a huge turn
you sort of talk about playing rock and
maybe and and sort of what your
character is doing yeah I think he's
facing the fear of being you know
ostracized for who he is and I think
there's a tragedy and not being able to
just be yourself you know and I think
that's what he's going through and yeah
I mean dealing with where he came from
and his relationships with his
stepfather and making the choice I don't
want to give away too much but the show
is a you know part of it is about a love
story more than more than the commentary
on any salacious nature of what was
going on so yeah it was it was really
excited I'm he's a hero you know that's
the way I looked at it so it was really
daunting and I could feel almost like
the presence of you know him especially
earlier and onset but I think just to
pay homage and respect to his legacy it
was just about being present and working
with great people like Jim and Jeremy
one of the things that you guys got to
film in Los Angeles which is a little
bit of rarity but it's you know you're
filming a show like this in LA and some
of the real places you know um you sort
of talk about what that meant and maybe
if you had a certain place you just
loved don't me I would say you know it's
very funny when I've ever done
work in New York like plays and
specifically Broadway I frequently read
biographies about either actors
directors or the history of Broadway
while I'm doing because it's such a a
romantic atmosphere to absorb and I've
never without not only mr. Robert Worley
but I've never really felt that way when
I've been working in Hollywood and you
know in Los Angeles but doing it was so
Renee I was like
this is the this is that gorgeous
romantic history of Hollywood that's
very real and very much a part of the
lineage of working here and you know
that kind of Wild Wild West feeling of
the beginning of these motion pictures
and making all these huge epics and the
costumes the sense being able to be in
LA for only accentuated all of that and
it was for me personally just as an
actor who's been working there it was a
it was a moving experience yeah by
Jeremy Sam I mean I think my first day
on set was at Paramount Pictures and we
were right kind of on Loudon such a
historic ground for so many
groundbreaking groundbreaking films and
TV shows and this is also my my my
television debut so just to have that
full experience in LA we also went to
Musso and Frank's which is just a
legendary in itself and you know to be
telling this story about this beautiful
Golden Age time but to be living in
present in these places where you know
these things took place conversations
like we're having took place special and
if you did feel a presence you felt in
essence kind of amongst the crew whether
it was within your costumes or your your
background extras you were transported
to this this time and it made it so much
fun but also easier to just really drop
in as the character because everything
around you looked and felt like of that
time totally just full of you know
everything from the costumes to the
makeup and you know Jim and I both had
to wear prosthetics everything fell just
extravagantly appropriate and just it
made it that much easier that everyone
was so great especially you know being
on a Ryan Murphy said I feel there's a
certain level of prestige and everyone
holds a certain level of respect for
each other behind the camera everywhere
in the makeup trailer so it was a
incredible you know scenario and it made
a joy to come to work every day Jeremy I
actually wanted to ask a question you
have had a lot of success on stage but
as you mentioned this is your
I'm being in the project like this if
you sort of talk about your first week
on set and maybe what you were feeling
and what surprised you I think you know
what's different about you know I have
just come off a run of Broadway and you
know working in the theater it is an
intimate experience your audience is
there and you get to go through things
beginning middle and end you know that
you press start and you don't stop till
you reach the curtain book so you know
TV you're now getting a little bit
differently so my first week was me just
spending time and doing you know the
same research that I always do when it's
with characters and just so I could feel
confident in grounded and one thing that
I love about working on camera and with
Brian is there is this this willing you
have to be willing to play and improvise
because a lot of the things that you're
creating happen on the day which is very
different than the other project where
you're you know spending weeks and weeks
of rehearsal to then present this
display or production um so there it was
it was cool to take some time to just be
free and kind of allow things to come
organically when I get on set me and
Jake spent you know some time together
and that was fun and we've come together
and just talk about the scene the day of
and be willing to try on different
things as it was being filmed so a
totally different medium but just the
same very exciting and thrilling you
guys have a fantastic day
thank you Steve you chose this